PAUL KINLAN: Hi guys,
I'm Paul Kinlan.
Welcome to our Chrome
apps special event.
I think it's a special event.
I'd like to introduce
you to Renato.
RENATO MANGINI: Why
is this special?
I mean--
PAUL KINLAN: Why
is it special?
RENATO MANGINI: Just because we
are both in the same place?
PAUL KINLAN: It is, right.
So I'm from London--
RENATO MANGINI: And
I'm from Brazil.
PAUL KINLAN: And we're here
in Mountain View.
We just came across all the
way especially today.
RENATO MANGINI: And we are both
developer advocates for
their Chrome.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, actually this
is a Chrome apps thing.
We work on Chrome.
We do lots of Chrome things.
Today's actually kind of special
because it's our
first, I think, talk about using
NodeJS libraries inside
Chrome applications.
For you guys who don't know,
NodeJS is, basically, in the
past, people have used it
as mainly a server-based
infrastructure, like a web
server, SMTP servers, FTP--
I was going to say FMTP.
I have no idea what that is.
It's probably rude.
But yeah, so a lot of people
have been using NodeJS,
JavaScript on the server to
build their applications.
Its asynchronous.
It's all JavaScript.
It's one single process.
So it's pretty crazy
to work with.
Basically, the whole thing
about NodeJS is that
everything that you develop and
build is all meant to be
asynchronous.
So if you have any code that
blocks, like making a database
call, actually, what should
happen is, it should sleep and
then, the next time the next
tick happens, maybe there's
some data ready for you--
RENATO MANGINI: Which is quite
similar as the JavaScript
runtime runs on the
browser, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, that's the
big thing that we are trying
to do inside the browser is
to make every single API
asynchronous.
So that the whole user interface
doesn't block when
you scroll.
Everyone knows what it's like
if you put a near-infinite
loop inside your code.
RENATO MANGINI: So NodeJS is
running JavaScript on the
server, basically?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, JavaScript on
the server, powered by V8.
And what the we're going to do
today, at least, is show you
how to run your NodeJS
applications.
Not all of them, because we
don't have all the API
support, through a tool, called
Browserify, which lets
you run NodeJS-based code inside
your applications, or
inside your web apps,
traditionally, but you'll
notice, from the actual project
itself, it doesn't
have access to, say, the network
sockets APIs, which,
if you're doing server-based
work, and this is a kind of
key thing for Chrome OS, at
least-- if you're doing
server-based work, you never
have the ability to, inside
the browser, open up a
socket, for instance.
And we can do that
inside Chrome.
So we're going to show you two
applications, how to build
them, and we're going
to do that today.
RENATO MANGINI: Excellent.
PAUL KINLAN: Are we good?
Should we go?
Should we jump in?
RENATO MANGINI: So just one
question before you start
diving into the code.
So the point here is that NodeJS
is good for running on
the server, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
RENATO MANGINI: So why
would we want to
run it on the browser?
And what's the difference
between NodeJS code running on
the server and running and
a Chrome-packaged app.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I think there's two
bits to this, right?
There's-- we're getting
developers to build web
applications, right?
And we want developers to build
web applications in
JavaScript for the entirety of
the stack, the client side,
and on the server side.
And what we're trying to do, at
least with getting NodeJS
modules to run inside the
browser is, we're saying that,
actually, NodeJS via the MPM
package manager has got a huge
ecosystem of libraries
out there--
work that's already been done
by developers to get
integration with FTP servers,
FTP clients, HTPP web servers,
all these types of things.
That connect and express--
these are middleware pieces of
software that run web servers
inside the server.
We should be able to take all
that code and then also run
that inside the client.
You might ask why you
want to run a
server inside the client.
If you look at Chrome OS, for
instance, one of the things
about Chrome OS is that there's
always been this
reliance on a remote server
for your web applications.
And we've always had packaged
applications, which we're
trying to say, offline first
is the way you should go.
You should build applications
that work offline inside a
packaged app.
RENATO MANGINI: But you can only
run offline applications
if all the data you need, and
all the processes you need,
it's on the client, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
So what we're trying
to do is say that--
I go to one of the big
use cases, right?
You look at the IDs that
are inside the browser,
JavaScript, HTML-based IDs for
developing web applications.
A lot of them coming inside the
browser, but they still
need a server to run and
debug the code, right?
If you look at people like Cloud
9 IDE, they basically
have a NodeJS background
service, essentially, where
you can connect to it, and you
can debug your application
inside the browser.
We want to make sure that if
you're building applications
on the web today for your
browser, then you should also
be able to, actually, run and
debug them inside your Chrome
OS machine.
OK, Chrome OS is one use case.
You bring that to Mac,
Windows, and Linux--
wherever Chrome is, that's a
pretty compelling story.
You have one piece of code that
can run across all these
different platforms on the
client, in the server, and all
these types of things.
RENATO MANGINI: And it would be
another compelling use case
for using the NodeJS libraries
on the browser--
distribution?
Because currently, if I ask my
mother to install NodeJS and
run an applications on her
non-Chrome OS machine, she
would probably have some
troubles with that.
So maybe the distribution model
for the web and for the
Chrome packaged app is very
compelling because it uses a
store, the Chrome web store.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so all these
apps, they're obviously
delivered through the Chrome
web store at the moment, or
still will be.
So the interesting thing is that
you can build this IDE --
I'm not saying you're mother's
going to use an IDE-- is your
mother a web developer?
RENATO MANGINI: I cannot
tell you that.
Maybe she works for Google,
I don't know.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, maybe.
If you want to have these
applications and make them
available offline, you
can install them
from the web store.
You don't have to install
NodeJS and all
these types of things.
You don't have to go and
install that whole
infrastructure.
The browser is the runtime.
The browser is this thing that
can go off and run all your
applications, and that's what
we want to try and enable.
And I think that's where Chrome
OS is going, is like,
these applications can live
inside the browser or even
outside the browser, but just
written with the same
technology stack all
the way through.
RENATO MANGINI: That is great.
PAUL KINLAN: So I think
it's pretty exciting.
Should we jump to some code?
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah?
RENATO MANGINI: Fine.
I love code.
PAUL KINLAN: You love code?
Really?
Nice.
Cool.
So we've got my Chrome screen
in front of us.
I think what we're going to do
first is actually show two
applications just to kind of
get the feel of what we're
actually trying to
build with these.
The first is a thing
called Markdown.
So for any of you guys--
oopsie daisy.
Sorry.
So for any of you guys who know
Markdown, and we've seen
some of these things in the
past, recently, where we're
trying to standardize the
Markdown editor, I basically
built a Markdown application--
RENATO MANGINI: Markdown
editor, right?
A
PAUL KINLAN: A Markdown
editor.
Its three or four
lines of code.
So yeah, this is the interesting
thing, right, is
that we have MPM, which is a
big package manager, node
package manager, for your web
services, which basically
allows you to install any piece
of code that's been put
in that repository into your
web server application.
Using Browserify, we can
actually do that inside Chrome
OS, or inside your Chrome
applications.
RENATO MANGINI: So you still use
the same package that are
MPM, but you use it on
your web application?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
There's a package called
Markdown, which was MPM
install Markdown, which
installed into my application,
and then it's like two lines of
code to actually interact
with that module.
So I'm going to show you,
roughly kind of what
it looks like now.
This is the code.
So testing, hello world.
It's just a simple--
and I can't spell.
I can't type either, which
is kind of cool--
but it's just a simple
application.
It does things where it can
integrate with a file system,
so I can then go and
say I'm going to
save this to my desktop.
So testing GDL--
RENATO MANGINI: So on the left,
you type the Markdown
syntax, and on the right you'll
get the HTML, the
beautified [? markup ?].
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
exactly, yeah.
So you get the rendered output
on the right hand side and the
actual raw text inside here.
This is kind of cool.
I kind of like this.
RENATO MANGINI: It looks like
it's not two lines of code,
three lines.
PAUL KINLAN: I do tell a
little bit of a fib.
The thing is that we're trying
to say, it's two lines--
did I say two lines?
About ten lines of code,
of my code, at least.
So the Markdown editor has
already been made and
distributed by our MPM.
So the idea behind MPM, at
least, and what we were saying
before is that there are
thousands and thousands of
modules, and thousands and
thousands of developer hours
that have been spent building
the JavaScript libraries up to
help you, as a developer,
build applications
that users will love.
And one of those things
is a Markdown module.
So should we jump
into the code?
Let me see if I can just
show you the code
that we have here.
This is what we're going
to build today.
So we go to source, index.js.
I do have a lot of extra code.
We're not going to go
too much into this.
And I do have a bug in some of
my code as well at the moment.
But essentially, this can
interact with the Chrome file
system, like with the user's
file system, and all
that type of stuff.
We're not going to go into that
part today because we
want to just talk about the node
part of this application.
So let's jump into the code.
So I'll do index.html, so you
can actually see, this is our
kind of basic structure
of our application.
We have some images
down the side.
They're not too important for
today, in fact, just to prove
it, I'm going to delete two of
them because we're not going
to use them.
And we have a text area where
we're going to input our text,
our Markdown code, our Markdown
code, and then an
HTML area on the right
hand side.
I used normal CSS to style it
up, nothing kind of special.
I don't even use Flexbox.
I was going to use Flexbox,
[INAUDIBLE]
it didn't matter at all.
So let's just jump into this.
v split index.js.
So index.js is the bit where
we're going to put all of our
logic for our Markdown editor,
which is this-- literally,
it's going to be 10
lines of code.
So I'm going to do the thing
that everyone hates, but I'm
going to do it onload.
So this is basically
just saying the
window onload event.
I don't want to do add
event listener--
it just adds too much
extra cruft.
But let's have a look.
So md element = document--
oops, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE]
This is boilerpate code.
And I can't type, still.
Markdown, there we are,
HTML = document.
I really can't type today--
by ID.
RENATO MANGINI: It's
the jetlag.
PAUL KINLAN: It's the jetlag.
I woke up at 3 o'clock this
morning, wide awake.
I thought, you know what?
I'm going to have
to go the gym.
So I went to the gym.
So this is the really
interesting bit, right?
This is, if you're a NodeJS
developer, you'll know this
bit just straight away.
We're going to use the required
syntax, Markdown.
And so what this will do, this
will actually pull in Markdown
that we've actually
pulled into our--
RENATO MANGINI: So the
require is like
import for other languages.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's
basically like an import and
include, those types
of things.
We have to do, this is just a
bit of, for brevity, is put
that on the end because I
just don't want to do
another line of code.
What you'll see now is, if
we try and run this, this
application won't work because
I actually haven't imported
the node package manager
system into our Chrome
application.
And I haven't run it
through Browserify.
So right now this won't
work, but I'm just
showing you the code.
So we'll go into this.
MDL, which is the markdown
area, dot
onkeypress = function.
Here we go.
output = Markdown.
I just realized I made
a really weird noise.
md.toHTML, that's the
one, mdl.value.
So what we're doing here, it's
relatively simple, we're
taking the data from the text
area, passing it through the
markdown system, and--
RENATO MANGINI: So on every
keypress, you run it through
the renderer?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's
pretty inefficient.
But yeah, it's pretty cool.
And I'm doing something we
probably shouldn't do as
well-- innerHTML = output,
and that's it.
That's all we need.
RENATO MANGINI: Is this
innerHTML = output a big
problem for a Chrome-patched app
as it is for a web page?
PAUL KINLAN: It's not
as big a problem.
We have content security
policy.
And by default, content security
policy inside Chrome
applications.
RENATO MANGINI: Because this is
one of the biggest source
of exploits, right?
On web pages.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it is.
Yes it is.
[INAUDIBLE]
But yeah, this is the
point, right?
We have this thing called
content security policy, which
basically says, well, I know
all the resources that my
application can access.
So I don't allow dynamic script
loading and injection
from third party sources.
I won't allow images to be
loaded in from other source as
well, and, likewise, with
cookies and all
that type of stuff.
And if we can disable those
things, and eval, and--
RENATO MANGINI: So it's
basically impossible to put a
script tag on HTML because
it doesn't evolve.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, with
Markdown, in some versions or
flavors of Markdown,
at least, you can
inject HTML code yourself.
Which the normal, plain HTML
code will be fine.
But if it injects, finds
a script tag, it
won't let you do it.
You can't run script
tags in line.
Eval is disabled as well.
So we can't do those
types of things.
So it's not great, from the
way that we encourage
developers to build applications
that interact
with the DOM, and make
new DOM elements, but
it's relatively safe.
So let's break out this.
The thing I really want to do
is, I will show you how to
build and bring in your
nodes modules.
So the basic thing we do, NPM
install, which, if you've
installed node inside your
development environment, NPM
basically comes pre-installed.
And we have the ability, it's
like kind of git, where it's
got a special set of
command lines.
Install is the ability to
install modules into your
local application working
directory.
So let's install Markdown.
It goes off, gets it, and if all
this works, this is cool.
So if I do a brief look at this,
we have this directory
called node modules--
Oopsie daisy, sorry--
with a Markdown module
inside there.
This is packaged up inside my
application when I deploy it,
so I know I've got all the
dependencies that I need.
If Markdown required other
dependencies for other node
modules, it'd bring them
and import them in.
RENATO MANGINI: And now you
are talking about NodeJS
specifically?
There is nothing related
to the Chrome
packaged app yet, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, this isn't
specific at all to Chrome
packaged apps.
This is just a very--
we want to use a basic
node module.
How do we actually use a node
module inside Chrome?
We're not quite there
just yet.
We have to do this thing
called Browserify.
Yeah, it's a really
nice project.
Basically, the reason why this
all works, and the reason we
can do today, is because an
external developer has
basically made it so that
you can run node
modules in the web.
And we're taking advantage of
all this functionality to say,
well, we can do is for our
Chrome applications now.
So Browserify is the project.
It's on github.com.
But basically, what we do is, we
import the Markdown module,
which is fine, and we
then output it to
a file called bundle.js.
So this is not going to make too
much sense, but if we look
at bundle.js, it's basically
including all the code that is
needed to run basic NodeJS
applications inside the
browser and also Chrome
applications.
RENATO MANGINI: So that's
the secret step.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it does
all the secret step.
I've done none of this work.
It's all been done by the
community at large, and we're
just taking advantage of that
for your Chrome applications.
But we'll jump out.
It's important, Markdown,
it's in there.
And if we jump into Chrome,
load unpacked extension,
projects, GPL, Markdown, styles,
we've added an in, and
this should, if we view the
code, this is our code, yep.
This is our proper project
testing, hello.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: --world.
Yeah, from, like, my user code,
I've already done a
couple of lines of basic code,
10 lines of code, a lot of is
bootstrap of bringing in
elements and all this type of
stuff, but we've literally
been able to build this
application out using other
third party modules, quickly
using the Node MPN package
manager, yeah,
and it's pretty cool.
RENATO MANGINI: Awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: It's pretty nice.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
really cool.
PAUL KINLAN: So do we have
any questions from--?
RENATO MANGINI: We
have some, but--
PAUL KINLAN: We can deal with,
actually, can we debug.
I think that's the biggest one,
right, is like, can we
debug a node application?
So the thing to notice about
this is, node is built on the
back of V8.
Chrome's JavaScript engine is
built on the back of V8.
There's a lot of things inside
of node which are purely
written in C, essentially.
They're like hard wrappers
to the V8 engine.
So what's actually happening now
is, this is really just an
emulation of node and its
libraries inside Chrome it's
not a full NodeJS system
inside Chrome.
So that might have some kind
of negative benefits, like
negative aspects to this, in
the sense that, if some
modules had been written in
C, and they're specially
optimized for node on the server
environment, we're not
necessarily going to get that
kind of performance out of it
because the buffer object, for
instance, in NodeJS, we have
to manage that ourselves.
We to manage that inside
JavaScript.
Inside node, that's actually
managed by a
basically native code.
So the interesting thing is, it
has a negative, which is,
potentially, performance.
I don't think it's going
to be that much
of a problem, though.
The benefit, though, and to
answer this question, is that
we can actually debug these
things a lot better inside the
Chrome dev tools.
The reason why we can debug
these things inside Chrome dev
tools, is, well, you'll
see it now.
Is it's just an HTML and
JavaScript web-based
application.
So if we go here, reload page,
so if we reload the page, we
should still have our break
points still set.
If we break into this, you'll
see it breaks into this
bundle.js, which is
the compiled code
from Browserify project.
So it's pretty cool, right?
I mean, we can do a whole
lot of stuff.
It doesn't make much sense for
me to show them too much else
about this.
But everything's JavaScript,
everything's imported inside
the browser, which means
that you can debug your
applications.
It doesn't mean that you can go
and debug your node-based
application on the server.
You still have to go through the
existing methods that you
used that way.
RENATO MANGINI: So basically,
what you're doing there, on
the debug part, you are
debugging the bundle js, and
the bundle js, it will be like
the "node runtime," quoted.
So does the bundle js--
what type of limitations, aside
from performance, that
you already mentioned?
PAUL KINLAN: So some
of the limitations
it has at the moment--
it's only got the basic APIs
of NodeJS stubbed out.
Which, for the majority
of modules, is fine.
It's absolutely fine.
But if you want to do network
sockets, for instance, or
serial port access, those types
of things, they don't
exist on the web.
So the engineers behind that
Browserify project have not
implemented them.
But that doesn't stop us from
doing it because the really
cool thing is that Chrome has
got, inside this packaged app,
this new apps platform module
at least, anyway, it's got
access to a whole load of
hardware based APIs.
So we can talk to serial ports,
network sockets, so we
can do TCP and UDP.
What else can we do,
USB, Bluetooth--
RENATO MANGINI: Bluetooth
on some platforms.
We have Windows access, we have
a different file system--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so we've got
file system API as well.
The FS module as well, inside
node, is pretty cool.
But what this allows us to do,
in quite a few cases, as long
as it's an asynchronous API
inside the NodeJS, is that we
can have a really good kind of
go at fleshing out the actual
implementation.
So we can provide the Chrome
implementation over, say, the
network socket API that maps
directly to the Chrome's
socket API.
RENATO MANGINI: Like
a wrapper?
Yeah, it's just basically
a wrapper.
And it's on github today.
I've already got one for net
module, which is what I'm
going to show you now.
So it's a nice lead in
there, thank you.
So this is our next
application.
It's not going to
look like much.
If you've ever done anything
with XML HTTP request, you'll
say, well, I can just use
XML HTTP request.
But this is all about
just doing a demo.
So news.ycombinator.org--
I really should do
my blog instead.
Port 80, because this
is a bug in my code.
And all it does is, it makes a
request out from my Chrome
packaged application.
And actually, rather than does
XML HTTP request, it uses the
net module inside Chrome OS,
well not inside Chrome OS,
NodeJS, so that we can actually
make our requests out
using the module.
In this case--
RENATO MANGINI: So it
does a raw TCP--
PAUL KINLAN: It does a raw TCP
connection and then writes the
HTTP request out
to the socket.
And then the web server
will respond, and we
just display the data.
So as you can see, I mean, it's
just telling you all the
header information and a whole
lot of other stuff there.
It's pretty cool.
I really want to show you
guys the code because I
really like this code.
Most of it's taken from the
NodeJS documentation, just to
kind of see how easily
it works.
Let me just remove this there.
So as you can see here, we have
the net module, require
net, this doesn't come with
Browserify, but I've made the
wrapper for Chrome, so we'll see
that in a second when we
get into the code.
We basically pass the URL.
This is actually a
really nice API.
Someone in the NodeJS community,
I think it actually
might be default inside node,
actually, they wrote a proper
URL object.
Which means that we don't have
this in the browser, right?
RENATO MANGINI: To deal with
schema, ports, and et cetera.
PAUL KINLAN: To deal with
schema, ports, passing, query
strings, path, the closest
that we get to it is the
location object.
I mean, we can't construct a
brand new location object just
inside the browser.
It's a real pain.
But now it's in node.
You just do, and here's the code
here, if we just zoom in
a bit more-- oh, I won't
zoom in that much.
url.pass, and it passes the
value, the string that we put
in and returns the url object.
It's beautiful.
It's really nice, and that's
all thanks to node and the
fact that we can run this inside
Chrome via Browserify.
So should we just jump in?
I mean, I've shown you the
code anyway, but we'll
probably just jump in
to show how easy it
is to do this thing?
RENATO MANGINI: Is it's like,
three lines of code?
PAUL KINLAN: No, this is
a little bit more.
It's four lines of code now.
Web requester.
So if we view index.html, you'll
see that I've just got
everything already
made for us.
It takes too much effort to go
and do all the html live.
So [? let's edit ?]
vsplit, I can't spell vsplit
at all today--
index.js.
Add it anyway, that's fine,
all right, cool.
And in this one, I've prepared
all the boilerplate
code ahead of time.
RENATO MANGINI: Ah, OK.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's just
jump into the code.
I actually have written it out
down here, so it's var net =
require net.
This is using the same NodeJS
import system to import the
net module.
Var url = require url.
And then var sys
= require sys.
And that's basically all of the
modules that we need for
our application.
Now the really cool thing about
this is that we're going
to basically pass the host.
This, I love this.
It sounds stupid.
It does sound stupid.
But I just love this module
because I can do
so much with it.
I'm just going to take some
values I'm going to use for
later on, port, and this is
why I love it, right?
Pass int, host.port,
or port 80.
So the bug that I had in my
code originally, it didn't
have this or 80, essentially.
So if you didn't put port in,
it'd just assume that there
was no port.
Host, host.hostname.
Cool.
And that's all we need
to pass it out.
If you've ever done anything
like this in JavaScript,
trying to pass out URL fragments
and syntax, like
some if someone's giving
you a URL, you'll
know how hard it is.
So it's just nice, the fact
that we can actually bring
this into our applications.
This is actually, if you use
Browserify just normally, this
is available to every
web application.
So if you need a URL object
parser that's the one to use.
So client, so if you're a NodeJS
developer, you'll know
this already.
net.creat net.create connection
with my options,
set some encoding, actually,
I put this in just
to be a nice citizen.
I actually haven't stubbed
out the code for this.
So right, this is the meat
of the code now.
Client connect, ooh, can't
spell function.
There we are.
RENATO MANGINI: We have some
YouTube commenters telling
that you will misspelled
require--
[INAUDIBLE] require.
PAUL KINLAN: Aww!
Nice, nice, real
time feedback.
RENATO MANGINI: Thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: I still
can't spell it.
There we are.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, so this is done live.
Only practiced lots of times,
as you can't tell, sorry.
Host.path, so this is going to
look like a bit of voodoo
magic, well, not necessarily
really voodoo magic, but
you'll see what I'm doing
in a second second.
So this is because we, as kind
of web developers, we know and
understand the structure of the
code and how to make an
HTTP request.
The thing about the NodeJS
stuff, this application, is
that we're using the
raw socket API.
It doesn't know how to make
an HTTP request, so we're
actually formulating the request
that we're going to
make out to the remote
service.
So once we have a connection,
and we know that we can
successfully connect it to the
service, we're going to build
out this request,
host, host.host.
I could've refracted this a
little bit more, I suppose,
slash n, slash n, boom,
client.write.
And I'm going to explain a lot
more about this right now.
So what we've done here is,
we've created a connection to
the URL that we specified
in the text box--
I couldn't think of the word,
then, to save my life.
We've basically passed the URL
out, we've made the connection
to the service, once we know
that we're connected, there's
an on event, essentially.
It's an [? eventer ?]
method inside NodeJS.
So it's the same style event
model, like event inventing
logic that you have, which is
different in normal website.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, this
is very common for node
developers they would look
at the code and--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
We formulate the request.
It's just a get request.
It doesn't do much else.
It takes the path, tells it it's
a HTTP 1.1 protocol, and
then gives it the host,
the host name, because
that's what we need.
And then it writes out
to the socket.
So what we've done in this part
now is that we've taken
this code, and we've basically
said, open the connection and
send the data to
the web server.
The web server will send us data
back, however, we can't
do anything with it just
yet because we've no
way to handle it.
So let's have a quick
go at that.
So client.on.
So this is another event.
I can't spell.
Data, oh wow.
Data--
and we're not going to do
too much with this.
result.innerText, yeah, it
can be multiple requests.
So let's do that.
data.toString, and
there we go.
I think we're all closed off.
RENATO MANGINI: So what you're
doing with the response from
the server is just
setting it on--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, we're just
setting it on the div, just to
show what's happening.
So the interesting thing is,
this, again, will not work.
RENATO MANGINI: Why?
PAUL KINLAN: Because we've
not imported the module.
So I actually have the URL.
I've not published it live
into MPM just yet because
there's a whole load of things
I want to get sorted out.
But it is on github.
So MPM install git,
github.com/paulk
inlan/net-chromify.git.
RENATO MANGINI: Installed?
PAUL KINLAN: It's actually
installed it from my local
system because I actually
had it on previously.
Demo fail.
But let's have a look.
Let's see if we can load--
what am I doing?
I apologize--
load it in.
Web requestor.
Testing.org It doesn't
have an index.html.
Oh, we've got an error.
Let's have a look what it is.
Hmm.
well, should we show off
the debugging support.
RENATO MANGINI: Oh, leave
the bug session, uh oh.
Leave the bug session.
Live the bug session.
There is one question
on YouTube .
[? Montis Lewis ?] is asking
where is window.require?
Because you call a require
method on the full name space.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, so let
me show you actually.
So where's the window.require?
This is interesting, right?
So this is exactly what
Browserify does for us.
Oh, you know why
it didn't work?
RENATO MANGINI: Why?
PAUL KINLAN: I'll tell you
why it didn't work.
So let's actually answer
that question.
So Browserify -r netChromify
net.
So map the net Chromify module
to the net name space.
-sys, and also include url
and output bundle.js.
So if we look at bundle--
I apologize again,
bundle.js this is
actually where it's defined.
RENATO MANGINI: All right, so
what Browserify did there is
imported out the node modules
that you specified, and
generated the bundle
without this--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so basically
if we do a search
for net, then it's basically
brought net
into this bundle object.
So bundle.js is a collection
of all our node modules.
It's a collection of all the
core functionality that's
needed via--
RENATO MANGINI: And what does it
also look for dependencies
inside those modules?
For example, if net depends
another module,
it does look for--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so I've
actually got a bug fix out as
well for this, inside
Browserify.
But essentially, if you look at
the Markdown project that
we had before, it had
some sub modules.
So if you go to require./
another js file, when you do
the Browserify process, it will
go and pass out all the
modules it needs to load in into
this one JavaScript file.
And to the same extent as well,
you have to prerequire
all the call libraries
yourself.
But it will spit out an error
that you can't find one of the
modules you'll need.
But the really interesting thing
is, generally, is if you
do an MPM install, you only
really have to do the
highlight, the top level module,
for it to go off and
go, well I know all the
node modules I need--
RENATO MANGINI: If if net
required a TCP module, I don't
even know if that is one, if you
do in MPM install net, the
TCP module would
also install--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I mean,
it's all part of it.
And net in our case here
is our own module.
But if we required any extra
modules, if we broke it up a
little bit to make the code a
bit more maintainable, it'll
bring all them in.
So it can do that.
So I actually want to
see if I fixed this.
News.ycominator.org--
let's do port 80 as well,
just in case, in case I
didn't fix the bugs.
No, it didn't work.
So yeah, this is live.
We had a demo fail today.
RENATO MANGINI: No problem,
I trust you
that the code is working.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank
you very much.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
really awesome.
So what it did there, you
created a simple code that
used the net module.
But the net module is
not Browserify.
It doesn't come with
Browserify, right?
So you wrote a wrapper around a
Chrome-packaged app, socket
APIs and converting those
APIs to the the same
syntax as net module.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
RENATO MANGINI: So you can use
exactly the same code that
uses net module, you can use it
on your Chrome [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
Basically, it's a complete
mapper to the node APIs.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
really cool.
PAUL KINLAN: So what's just kind
of cool is, if we want to
access serial ports and all
these types of things, it's
pretty cool.
RENATO MANGINI: So we can have
developers creating those
wrappers for every API
that's not supported
by Browserify, fight?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
exactly, yeah.
RENATO MANGINI: Awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: So the really
interesting thing as well is
that the net module itself
doesn't come with a server.
So I'll rephrase it.
It comes with client
connections.
You make the connection, but
you can also create a TCP
server with it as well.
And I think from our talk two
or three weeks ago, when we
talked about Chrome actually has
listen and accept methods
now, so you can actually have
Chrome running as a web server
or any type of server
that you want.
I'm doing a little
bit more work.
It's not an amazing amount, but
what's going to happen is,
basically, you're going to be
able to run your node-based
server, in theory, "in theory,"
inside your Chrome
application.
So if we have the complete
mapping between the net name
space, then it'd be so cool if
we can get, you know, you're
building applications with
Express or any of the node
middleware modules for building
web servers--
you could actually run your web
server and all your code
inside your app.
And when you're thinking about
these new kind of native like
applications where you have all
the logic on the server,
and, well, you're offline, what
happens, well you can
have the similar type of
logic on the client.
And then your pure UI client
itself still make the same
types of requests out
to the server.
It doesn't really have
to know it's offline.
It just says, well, I'm going
to make these requests, and
they get delegated back to our
application and then to the
main web server.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
really cool.
And we have a huge community of
NodeJS developers, right?
So we have a huge amount of
projects using NodeJS.
And if those projects can run on
the client side, and if it
makes sense for those projects
to run on the client side,
it's interesting for users and
for developers that have a
user base much bigger
than the--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it kickstarts
your whole
development process.
You can built these native type
applications using code
that developers have
already made.
And if you don't want to use
node, then we still have our
raw, kind of low level socket
APIs for instance, for
networking.
Like the raw APIs that you
might need, but a lot of
developers don't like dealing
with raw APIs.
But we have the ability to go
deep into the raw API or
higher level with the node
modules at least.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
really cool.
We are running out of time,
maybe we can jump--
PAUL KINLAN: Should we jump
into some questions?
RENATO MANGINI: OK, so the first
question from Luis, from
Phoenix, how does MPM fit in?
This question was made before
the session begin, but even
though, I think you can
give a quick answer.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so I mean,
I hope it's been kind of
relatively clear about how MPM
fits in, is that it's just
part of your development
life cycle, right?
So you'll have your application
that you're
developing, say, on your Mac
box, or Linux, Windows.
And you'll do MPM install.
You'll install the
modules locally.
They don't have to be locally
installed because,
essentially, what happens is,
Browserify inspects all the
node modules that you've
installed into your
application space, essentially,
and then says,
well, that's cool, they're
there, but we're going to make
this big bundle file.
And then you'll install that
inside the browser.
RENATO MANGINI: So the user of
your web application that's
uses Browserify doesn't need to
have node or MPM installed?
PAUL KINLAN: It's just
you as a developer.
And if you're developing node
based applications, you'll be
using MPM anyway.
It's the same time of process,
apart from this Browserify
step, which you basically have
to use to convert your code
and import all the module syntax
[? and all type of ?]
stuff in.
RENATO MANGINI: That's cool.
PAUL KINLAN: It fits in.
RENATO MANGINI: The
next question--
what are the sandboxing
restrictions?
PAUL KINLAN: So I suppose
there's a couple of different
types of answers that we
can deal with on this.
The sandboxing, it comes in in
a couple of different senses.
There's the content security
policy, which basically
sandboxes the things that you
can inject into a page.
So you can't include external
resources unless you
explicitly, in your manifest,
allow them.
If you're making requests out
to the services, then, if
you're using the node based net
API for sandboxing, then
it's all permission based
inside Chrome.
So let me just, if we can, jump
back into some code for
the web requestor.
The manifest basically has this
line at the bottom which
I tried to highlight,
socket TCP connect.
RENATO MANGINI: So you have
the same restrictions as a
standard JavaScript code running
on a Chrome packaged
app, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
RENATO MANGINI: It's
exactly the same.
You don't run native code,
you don't run to the
native part of NodeJS.
It's just JavaScript.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, you don't run
the native part of NodeJS.
And if we, for instance, used
the net module, for instance,
that breaks out to the
Chrome.socket API, which is
permission based.
So when you actually want to
deal with these lower level
APIs and these kind of more
advanced functionality than
you get with a normal
application, then this is
actually done through a
permission based system.
So we have this exact same
sandboxing model as a normal
website, a normal web page.
Web pages can't request data
automatically from another web
page, like inject--
they just can't go
across process.
So it's the same type of
sandboxing models.
RENATO MANGINI: OK, next
question from Juice, what
build is this available in?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so this
should work in--
I think we're at
beta aren't we?
We're in beta for the beta
channel at least--
RENATO MANGINI: The 23?
PAUL KINLAN: 23
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so the best
place says, this is all still
kind of in development and
experimental at the moment.
But it's getting to the point
where we want to get it live.
The main thing to notice is
that I'd say, work on Dev
Channel and Canary because
there are still kind of
changes to some of the APIs
going on, and while the
network socket API hasn't
changed in a long time, and
I'm pretty sure it wont', we've
just got to make sure
it's not unstable just yet.
So I would work on the
Dev Channel for now.
Work with Browserify as well--
RENATO MANGINI: Especially if
you use the TCP lesson, and
TCP lesson is only on Canary.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
so TCP lesson,
actually, is only on Canary.
And it's only on the
experimental flag as well, I
think, isn't it?
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So if you want to
do server-based work, we'd
love you guys to go out and demo
it and kind of work on it
and give us a lot of feedback
about that.
But yeah.
RENATO MANGINI: Where
we can find more
docs on patched apps?
PAUL KINLAN: So
developer.chrome.com/apps,
that includes more of all
of our documentation.
It actually doesn't have this
web, I can't believe someone
actually noticed this unless
they looked at the code.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah,
that's really cool.
PAUL KINLAN: That's actually
pretty cool.
RENATO MANGINI: Do you
want to explain this?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, webkit
app region--
webkit app region is a piece of
CSS syntax that allows you
to [INAUDIBLE], because you
notice in this application
that we have here, we don't
actually have a title bar.
And if you don't have a title
bar, how do you drag the
application around?
Well, webkit app region is the
piece of CSS syntax that you
use to actually define
what's draggable.
So I've made the left
bar here draggable.
And if we inspect element.
RENATO MANGINI: Actually, the
webkit app region specifies
what is not draggable.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, and then you
specify it in here, the drag.
So basically, you've specified
the drag area.
So you can say non draggable.
We don't actually have
that documentation.
We need to get some
documentation for that because
it's very Chrome
apps specific.
RENATO MANGINI: OK, so do we
need to make a difference HTTP
package to use the Chrome
TCP list editor?
PAUL KINLAN: So I was under the
impression that the HTTP
package was mainly about making
XML HTTP requests,
like, style requests out, which
is kind of supported
with XML HTTP request, anyway,
inside the Browserify project.
If you want to go and make a
special Chrome-only version
that uses the sockets, then
that's perfectly possible, but
I think the code's
already there.
For the actual TCP
listener, that's
included in the net project.
So in theory, if there was a
server component to the HTTP
project, and it included the net
module, then they should
just work in theory
and get pulled in.
I will say now that the code
inside the net module for
creating server based accept
and listen modules, it
doesn't work yet.
And I'm going to
get live soon.
I've got to run through
all the unit tests.
RENATO MANGINI: But you don't
need a different HTTP package?
I mean, you need a wrapper
around the HTTP package?
There's already an HTTP package,
and the way that
Browserify works is, you have
HTTP-Browserify, it will use
that module.
So you can make your own
Browserify package to replace
what comes by default.
RENATO MANGINI: So your
application that is the HTTP
package doesn't change if you
provide the same service?
PAUL KINLAN: If you provide the
same base level API, you
should be fine.
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
And here we come to the last
question on Moderator, is
there a register to compare
builds in node packages versus
what has been done like
your net package?
PAUL KINLAN: We could
start a list.
So could we start a
list somewhere?
So the interesting thing is that
we definitely don't want
to fork the Browserify
project.
But the Browserify project
basically says these modules
need work to do.
But like we said in the previous
question is, if you
make the module itself
net-browserify, or
http-browserify, and then you
import that into your project,
and you're via MPM install of
that module, then Browserify
will delegate to that
piece functionality.
So you can override all those
different areas with your own
functionality.
So we do need a lot more.
I've only worked on net because
it was the sexiest one
to work on.
Because I could build a web
server inside the browser.
RENATO MANGINI: But it doesn't
include robots.
Why is this the sexiest?
PAUL KINLAN: It doesn't
include the robots?
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, it should
include robots, should
be the sexiest--
PAUL KINLAN: So, funny
you should say this.
There's a whole competition now
for accessing Mindstorms,
Arduinos, what else is there,
the AR drones, and all those
types of things, where people
are doing it inside NodeJS.
And we've written our own stuff
to access a Mindstorm
before in Chrome, and
we've also written--
RENATO MANGINI: We definitely
should do that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I
mean, it's already
been done in node.
So the thing that should happen
is, we should just
provide the base API wrapper.
RENATO MANGINI: That's true.
PAUL KINLAN: And then all these
applications that are
written for node should work--
RENATO MANGINI: Controlling a
robot using a web application.
PAUL KINLAN: We should do it.
I mean, we just need to get
those extra bits filled in.
And if anyone wants to
help me, email me
paulkinlan@google.com, and
we'll get started.
RENATO MANGINI: OK, and
let me check if
there is anymore questions?
PAUL KINLAN: Why Vim?
I like Vim.
Renato's done some really cool
stuff with Sublime, which
we'll show in a future
episode.
So I might move to that
at some point.
RENATO MANGINI: Maybe I can do
the same for vi, because I
also love vi.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, [INAUDIBLE]
special Vim package or bundle,
or whatever they are called.
RENATO MANGINI: OK, so we
are pretty much done.
PAUL KINLAN: I think we're
pretty much done.
Thanks, guys, for listening.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
RENATO MANGINI: I'm Renato
Mangin, thanks for coming.
PAUL KINLAN: And we'll
see you next week.